what what what
oh he's grabbing my rapier let it go
jackass is there any practicality to
a lightsaber staff one of the reasons
why this fight is so seamless
it's not the editing
this episode of stuntmen react is
brought to you by raycon stick around to
the end to see how you can get 15
off your first pair hey everyone welcome
back to another episode of stuntmen
react we're joined here by luke
lafontaine who specializes in
sword and weapon choreography for film
among other things luke can you tell us
a little bit about yourself
my career started back in the late 80s i
was fortunate enough to work
on army of darkness
hook i'm sick
beowulf
my job as a choreographer is to make
sure
that i choreograph the fight make sure
that it's realistic
make sure that everybody who's working
on it is happy and keeping all the
actors and stunt people perfectly safe
luke the last time i saw you i was in
full orc makeup in the middle of utah
you were sweating in blue man it was
good to see you
so guys we got a lot of exciting clips
to talk about so
let's jump right in
dude young tom cruise this is a nice bit
it's a nice touch with his hands coming
down the coat sleeves and his foot going
back
he's preparing he's getting ready
one of the reasons why this fight is so
seamless it's not the editing
this fight took months these guys ran
this whole fight
over and over and over because there's
so many subtle
timing bits that it would have been
almost impossible
to accomplish this fight with less
rehearsal and it's not
holy editing that's tom doing it he's a
master of dedication
everything that i've heard is that he is
just a workhorse
he's two thousand percent dedicated and
he just never stops
there are things that are incorrect in
this fight in terms of the gripping of
the swords
their hands aren't quite spaced apart as
much as they need to be
there are a couple of cuts where they're
coming way back behind their head
and then cutting forward where you cut
from is equal to time
so all this time back here you could be
cutting me
so until my sword breaks the plane i'm
not a danger till here but again there
are also a lot of period correct
sword techniques in here him bracing
with the back hand
that's an actual japanese battlefield
technique where when you wanted to brace
the blade
you'd brace the katana on your forearm
because the moon a the back edge
wasn't sharp tom's got his hand open and
flat which is also
realistic you know he wouldn't be
gripping the blade oh god that's
something you want to do with a sharp
object that's three and a half feet long
one of the things you have to give these
guys credit for is a hand to hand fight
is a hell of a lot easier to do than a
sword fight why
you're only responsible for the length
of your arm try adding three feet
so you've got to pay attention out here
where the point of the sword is
i could stop from poking you in the eye
i don't know that i can stop from poking
you with a sword if i'm not used to
wielding a sword
how often do accidents happen on set i'm
not just talking like banging fingers
like more serious accidents with
sword fights they happen if you get the
opportunity to really train your actors
they don't
there's only one thing that you can do
to injure somebody in a sword fight
if you ruin your distancing that's how
somebody gets hit with a sword
if i screw the timing up if i'm in my
correct distance the blade will still
pass through and miss you by two inches
but it happens it happens i think how
they have you break down
and just give me your impression on
probably the most iconic sword fight
saber fight if you will in media which
is the
lightsaber fight from episode one the
phantom menace
[Applause]
this fight is incredibly complicated
and it was choreographed by ray park
initially
with another czechoslovakian stunt guy
that's how
ray got the part ray is really giving
in this fight and it's why no one else
will ever be darth maul
is there any practicality to a
lightsaber staff no your opinion no no
no and i'm going to tell you why the
problem is you've now
created the simplest and most complex
weapon
in the history of films do you ever
notice when these guys all
swing really hard they make these power
swings the blade's made out of light
it doesn't weigh anything why would you
have to swing it hard
the bottom line is it's a lightsaber
it's a laser it's made out of light it
wouldn't weigh anything
you could fence these weapons the
problem with that
is now you're locked into a very very
specific sword fight style
that doesn't always depict drama
initially before all of the weird
subsets
the jedi were samurai that's what they
were meant as the influence for star
wars comes from kurosawa films
it comes from tashira mafuni george
lucas wanted to cast
mifune as obi-wan wow man initially that
was
his first choice
man this is a good sword fight there's a
lot of techniques in here they're doing
8 10 12 moves at a time
there's a perry i disagree with the
behind the back perry is
that's sort of just nonsense but it's
okay
because again it's choreography but if
you look at the way ray moves look at
when ray turns his back
ray turns his back but ray's got a blade
moving the entire time
you've got to deal with ray's blade
before you can get a chance to cut him
across the back
so right here there's a lot of criticism
about how their swords are meeting in
the space between their bodies versus
like blocking the blade in front of his
body and sword fighting are you
fighting in front of yourself are you
fighting around yourself both
some martial disciplines trained to meet
in front of you on center line
but in combat you'll see people parrying
too soon certain fights got guilty of
this
later on in william hobbs career he had
to enact
safety protocol and if you look at rob
roy
there's an instance where you can see
the safety protocol in the choreography
where they go to the parry first
this is a really difficult piece of
choreo and the only other problem that
you see here is those were all cuts
made by tim there's two thrusts all the
rest of these are cuts
a transitional rapier is not a super
effective cutting weapon
in terms of if liam hadn't paired that
he would have gotten a very superficial
cut on the arm or the chest
whereas if those had all been thrusts he
would have been in a lot more trouble
here liam's bracing his wrist now would
he really do that
more than likely not because you won't
come to on guard if you don't have to
what is on guard for those of us who
don't speak french let me get a prop
a prop sword real quick so i can
actually illustrate this better this
might be a little long but
that's okay so if we were
sword fighting in chairs i'm not in on
guard right now
i'm also not in on guard right now if
you're going to come on guard in a sword
fight it's generally putting the blade
in between you and your opponent
he's playing the weight of the sword a
lot the sword did weigh
more than the rapier but you'd keep that
sword center guard of your body
even if you didn't have the tip up is
that just like it takes a lot of energy
to always be holding your sword up yeah
let me tell you something
when you go full out you're tired every
time i do this
i'm using all the muscles in my forearms
and my shoulders
and it's why sword fights like this are
brilliant it
depicts the drama of the reality of what
a sword fight is
he was already out of position he wasn't
even in danger of being cut there look
he's not getting cut there he cut four
feet off his body
so at what point do you balance the
visual effect the dramatic effects to
the realism that the audience can't
quite pick up on you know
that has a lot to do with the director
and the actors if the director
and the actors have fallen in love with
something there's not much you can do
about it as a choreographer
rob roy would not be sword fighting in
this manner see that giant swipe and
stumbles forward
they're making them like a caveman here
that's not the way they fence those
swords
there's a problem with this moment
[Music]
drop your sword
it's real simple oh he's grabbing my
rapier let it go jackass
then he's not going to cleave your
entire chest open and
leave a giant 11 inch gaping wound
could you just yank it out no no really
no it's very strange
because if i grip your blade my arm can
move too
and it takes three or four yanks and
more or less most of the time you're
wearing gloves
so if you yank and i go with it i can
still hold on to your blade
i can't believe you're not subscribed
this is like your 12th video you've been
watching
what the hell's the matter with you look
i've been in the film industry
for over 38 years this channel
and these guys are brilliant the
creativity and the amount of work that
they put in
you're never gonna go wrong watching
this channel
there's always awesome content so
subscribe trust me
you'll be glad you did
[Music]
this is
hold on my number's only
you did the fight choreography for
avengement and you actually are up for a
taurus award yeah i was working under a
stunt coordinator in england by the name
of dan stiles
dan had choreographed the fights yes i
was brought in
to tweak and fix and change some things
that scott adkins wanted changed
and added
this fight scene we should have had
eight or nine days to shoot it yeah
we had two oh shoot we shot this whole
fight scene in two days
these were hard rubber and balsa wood
weapons
about 96 of the hits in this are all
real scots making contact
with all these guys we doubled scott for
one
tiny thing in this entire fight because
i kind of demanded it that slam was that
a double there or was he still taking
that stuff no that was scott
really scott took that hit
[Music]
that's the only spot where we doubled
scott the flip
that fall over the table could scott do
that hell yeah scott could do that but
you know it's my job to make sure that
scott did this
he's got another really dangerous [ __ ]
scott wound up doing anyway we just
doubled him for that roll over the table
that was it
to do this in two days is really insane
do you think having the eight nine days
what would you have changed
i think quite honestly within eight or
nine days the fight would have actually
got a teeny bit longer because scott's
famous for that
when scott says something you go with it
because he knows better but we would
have taken our time
i think the fight is shot brilliantly i
think it all works great
the end product may have been kind of
the same because like you guys clearly
knocked it out in two days here
well i'll tell you why we knocked this
out in two days we knocked this out in
two days because of scott
any other actor could not have done this
in two days they just couldn't he just
turns the energy on every time
he just turns the energy on to 200 and
he just keeps going take after take
after take
you know i'm assuming you want to avoid
just slipping and getting a knife in
your eye
so is it mostly scott that's actually
holding the wrist and the other guy's
just
basically it's a lot of what's called
reverse tension
the actor with the knife is actually
pulling away and the other actor is
holding them there
so if the actor holding him slips the
knife goes away from you not towards you
but you get all the like the muscles you
get all the muscles shaky and everything
yeah it's super cool yeah
[Music]
all right comment request time here's
what i'm looking for from you guys i
want
all of you to suggest the best vehicle
stunts that you can think of car chases
plane chases
train chases you name it leave a comment
down below with your favorite
vehicle-based stunt
and we're gonna take those and build a
compilation for our next stuntman react
i'm very proud of this fight now we all
worked really hard on this fight again
this bite should have had three or four
or five days this was one day
it wasn't even one full day it was a
three-quarter day that we had to do this
whole fight that's insane
i faced you
with the exception of display i feel
like it's like
jake's knife and that is a cold steel
xlr spotter that we dulled
and made up a stunt weapon for but you
see as a bladed weapons fight i'm really
trying to get
that line where it looks like they're
really trying to cut each other these
boys are really close
dude that stab so sketchy so he was
offline he was offline slightly but this
is also scott's movement
scott stayed there yeah he might have
gotten scraped
there's the catch there's the homage
that was stolen for
game of thrones
dude that camera work was solid too one
of the things that helped with this
fight scene was that we had
almost 360 degrees that we could shoot
that's nice
in terms of what we were looking at we
could use almost all of it but
you know we had to maintain continuity
and had to stay on the right side of the
line you know i really liked it when we
went into the really wide shots scott
was always really instrumental in terms
of talking about camera
scott is brilliant in terms of knowing
how
he should come across in a movie he
should direct i think it's a matter of
time
it is just a matter of time before scott
will direct a whole loan from it scott
knows what works and what doesn't
these fights would not have come out
this way it wasn't for scott
you know when you work with the man you
see that he makes
anything work this fight's not brilliant
because of me this fight's brilliant
because of
scott and marco their physical
performance and their acting here
really tells this story but the thing
that's brilliant about these guys
is they know themselves on camera they
know what works
there's a coup de grace coming up thanks
to the director jesse johnson
not done yet
what what what
you just cut out his liver and he's
going to feed it to him wow
watch me oh he's going to eat it he's
not he's being interested
himself what
[Laughter]
jesse johnson came up with this and it
was a moment of brilliance because
it shocks audiences it stays with you
hey everybody i'd like to thank raycon
for sponsoring this video you might
remember in the last sponsor segment
with raycon i mentioned that i was
sending a pair to my dad
he got back to me and he's like nico i'm
really enjoying these everyday e25s in
fact here's the things i'm enjoying
about them
i'm enjoying the fact that they have a
seamless bluetooth connection i'm
enjoying their sleek and stylish design
i'm enjoying their sound quality with
the extra great sounding bass that they
have
he also really likes the fact that you
can recharge the earbuds up to four
times within their carrying case
which is really cool and you know i sent
him a blue pair he didn't have any say
in the matter but if you go online and
buy yourself a pair you can pick a bunch
of different colors
so you can pick one that suits your
personality go to buy your acon.com
corridor crew to get 15 off of your
order these earbuds are about half the
price of other top audio brands while
achieving the same level of quality it's
good stuff so we would love for you guys
to leave a comment down below of your
favorite sword
scene and we're gonna bring luke back on
hopefully i'm saying this without asking
luke but i'm assuming you'd be down to
come back on
and we'll break it down because there
are a lot of good sword fights that just
need to be talked about luke that was
super super super cool for you to share
these stories i loved having perspective
of someone who can actually speak to
weapon-based fighting on the show
thank you so much for joining us as
always i had a great time it's great
seeing you guys and thank you for having
me i hope
you know i didn't bag on anybody too
hard i don't think but i know
again i had a great time thanks for
being here if you guys would like to
check out more of luke's work you can
head on over to his website at war
studios.com there's a link down in the
description below as well as to a couple
other things that
luke has worked on so go check it out
send him some love
thank you so much for being on the show
we'll see you hopefully at some point in
the future
i'll see you guys soon